[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Welcome back, everybody.
So now we're going to hear
from two young investigators.
So the first will
be Sonja Swanson
who's an assistant professor in
the Department of Epidemiology
at the Erasmus Medical Center
in Rotterdam, the Netherlands.
She also holds an adjunct
affiliation with us
at the Harvard Chan
School of Public Health.
A lot of her work is on
estimating causal effects
in epidemiology, so a
little bit of a continuation
of this theme, but in
the particular domain
of neuropsychiatric disorders
and related health outcomes
and has a particular interest
in prevention and treatment
strategies.
And so she's going to talk about
biological and social processes
underlying mental health, and
how epidemiologists can help
articulate
patient-centered questions
and combine appropriate data and
analyzes to try to answer them.
And then we'll hear
from John Jackson, who's
assistant professor who
holds a dual appointment
in epidemiology and mental
health at Johns Hopkins.
His methods research focuses
on identifying, refining,
and evaluating interventions
to eliminate health and health
care disparities, and
developing methods
to improve the transparency and
conduct of occupational studies
and post hoc analyzes
of clinical trials.
That's after the clinical
trial is done and you go back
and you mine it for data
that wasn't necessarily
the focus of the
randomized intervention.
His work focuses on
understanding and reducing
the excess morbidity and
mortality in patients
with mental illness using
state of the art methods
to provide insight
about effectiveness
of potential interventions.
And today's talk will focus,
I think in particular,
on reducing health
disparities in this domain.
And I'll leave it
at that thought.
Why don't you guys come on up.
[APPLAUSE]
- Great.
So thank you so much
for having me here.
I'm thrilled to be
part of this event.
And I just want to thank
the Radcliffe Institute
in particular for
hosting not just today's
event, but this entire series.
So as Janet mentioned,
I'm going to be talking
about the epidemiology of
neurological and psychiatric
disorders, and I wanted
to start with just
going through what I see as the
big questions in this field.
And these are probably not
unlike the big questions
in any sort of subfield
of epidemiology.
So we want to know, how many
people suffer from dementia?
Who is at highest risk
of bipolar disorder?
How can we prevent
schizophrenia?
How can we treat depression?
How can we reduce the
negative consequences
of eating disorders?
And so these are the
big kinds of questions
that motivated me to
get into epidemiology,
and the kinds of questions
that underlie a lot of the work
that I do and my colleagues
do across the world.
However, a lot of the work--
as Janet kind of alluded
to already-- that I work
on is actually also getting
into the methods of this.
So not just how do we answer
these questions, but how
do we answer them better.
How do we improve the ways
that we answer these questions.
I didn't want this to be a
very mathematical talk, though,
so what I'm going to do is kind
of go through a little bit more
of the philosophy of doing
that in a sound manner.
And in particular, I
want to try to walk us
through a couple of steps
in this scientific process.
So how do we start with one
of those really big questions
and try to tackle that?
And what we want to do is we
have to distill it down to some
more precise, more manageable,
but still quite relevant
questions.
And once we have a more
precise question stated,
we can go on to collect
and analyze data,
to obtain some answer
to that question,
and then discuss
the results of that
as transparently as we can.
Now the last up iteration
I just want to underscore
is really important here.
Science is a process.
It's not an end
result. I'm not going
to talk as much about the
iteration part of this,
but I just want us to be mindful
that this sometimes means going
back up to that big question.
Sometimes refining
our sub-question,
sometimes collecting new
data, sometimes re-analyzing
and reinterpreting the
results of that data.
And so what I'm going to do
is go through this process
together with two
questions that I've kind of
worked with in my research.
And the first big
question I want to ask
is just, how many
adolescents in the US
actually have an
eating disorder?
How would we try to obtain an
estimate for this question?
Now before I go into making
that a more precise question,
I want to give just
a little bit more
background on eating
disorders for those that
are less familiar with them.
So traditionally, there were
two types of eating disorders
that were recognized by
medical professionals, anorexia
and bulimia nervosa.
There's specific
criteria that you
need to meet in order to get a
diagnosis of either of these.
I'm not going to go
through all the specifics,
but essentially anorexia
is characterized
by this low weight,
fear of weight gain,
and a disturbance in how
one experiences their shape
and weight.
Whereas bulimia is characterized
by having binge eating,
so overeating with
loss of control,
and compensatory behaviors
such as self-induced vomiting.
More recently there was another
eating disorder recognized,
a binge eating disorder, and
then everything else kind of
falls under this other category,
this catchall, not otherwise
specified diagnosis for
eating disorders that don't
meet these strict criteria.
So one thing to keep in mind
is that with eating disorders
the majority of patients that
present for care actually
fall under this not
otherwise specified category.
So with that in mind, let's
go back to our big question--
how many adolescents in the
US have an eating disorder--
and try to distill
it to some more
precise manageable questions.
And here I think it's important
to think through our motivation
for asking that question
in the first place.
So one possible
motivation is that we're
trying to get some estimate
at how many individuals would
benefit from some sort of care.
And this is already
sort of fuzzy.
This is not a precise
enough question yet,
but this gets at
the idea that we
might want to know about any
eating disorder, or maybe even
anyone with a symptom
of an eating disorder.
And that's the kind of number
that we're kind of setting out
to get.
Another possibility
is that we're
interested in getting the
proportion of individuals
with one of the
specific subtypes
or a couple different
listed subtypes.
So we might want to know how
many have anorexia or bulimia,
for example.
And then finally, another reason
we might be motivated for this
is that we're
trying to understand
how to allocate resources
for care as it's currently
being sought.
And in this case, we
wouldn't necessarily
want to know how
many individuals
have an eating disorder, but
how many seek treatment for it.
So when I put
these side by side,
hopefully it's obvious that
they're different questions
and we're going to get
different answers to them.
And that'd be true
if we did this
with any other
psychiatric disorder.
That'd be true if we did
this with cancer, with HIV,
or anything else.
One of the challenges in
psychiatric disorders,
though, is that there
can be huge differences
between these three questions.
That's a very different
issue between A and B
there because of
these fuzzy boundaries
of what the definitions
of our disorders are,
and there's a huge
difference between B and C
because there's
a lot of barriers
to treatment like stigma, having
a lack of insurance coverage,
and so on.
And so actually
in work that I've
done trying to answer
these questions with some
of my colleagues, we get
very different estimates.
We'd say that something like 1
in 10 for the first question,
1 in 100 for the second
question, and one in 1,000
for the third.
So just absolutely
enormous differences here.
Now, again, you might say,
of course they're different.
I see that they're different.
This is the end
of the story here.
But part of the
process of science
is understanding where
these numbers get used
for the next question we ask.
So if we're asking
who is at highest risk
for eating disorder,
it's important
that we know which
kind of category
we're starting to dissect from.
In particular, if we turn to
research as it was historically
done in eating disorders,
most of the research
was done in just clinical
or specialty care settings.
So they were only
recruiting patients
from these settings
who by definition were
seeking treatment.
What this means is
that we were really
missing the full picture of
who is most vulnerable to have
an eating disorder.
We were missing
out on who actually
has an eating disorder,
because we were actually,
by definition, looking at who
is most likely to seek care
for it.
And so what I want
to do next is just
go through some
misconceptions that
followed from that line of
research, and many of these
are probably
familiar to you when
you think of the prototypical
eating disorder patient.
So first, it's been
kind of long thought
that eating disorders
don't affect males.
Indeed, when we look at
treatment seeking samples,
it's almost a 10 to 1 ratio.
And this is such a
predominant belief
that's quoted in most
medical textbooks.
It's quoted in the
DSM, and this is really
this propagated belief.
When we look at some of the
community-based samples,
however, the ratio of females
to males is closer to two
to three to one.
And for some of the
specific subtypes,
it's actually close to 1 to 1.
So yes, they may affect
females more generally,
but there's such a
bigger discrepancy
in terms of the
treatment-seeking numbers
than the
community-based numbers.
The same could be true--
said for minorities for
looking across Western cultures
versus non-western
cultures, looking
across socioeconomic status.
So when we look at who
actually in a community sample
meets criteria for
an eating disorder,
there aren't as
big of differences
as we get in the
treatment-seeking samples.
And then finally, based on
treatment-seeking samples,
we tend to believe that
eating disorders onset in late
adolescence or early adulthood.
This is actually more
in line with when
they start seeking
care, but the symptoms
may start occurring
many years before.
And so this just
underscores that we're
missing an opportunity
to intervene much earlier
in the process based on this
kind of misinterpretation
of the data.
Now another thing
to keep in mind
when we are trying to
refine our question
is to think about when
we're asking about.
In particular, when we're
thinking about specific eating
disorders subtypes.
So I know this is a
very colorful graph,
but just to orient you each row
represents a particular patient
who at the beginning of
the 12 year follow-up
met criteria for one
specific eating disorder.
And so if we look across just
one particular row, every time
we see the color
change in that row that
means that the diagnosis that
we would give to that patient
at that moment in
time would change.
And so if you wanted to get an
estimate of how many patients
have anorexia in
this sample, you
get very different estimates
if you looked at one
particular time, or if you
asked about their entire history
or just the past year.
And so this is just
something we have
to be mindful of when we're
asking these kinds of questions
is what is the precise
question that we're
trying to obtain from our data.
So then let's go back
to our step-by-step.
We started with this
really big question,
how many adolescents
have an eating disorder?
And one possible way that we
could distill this question
would be to ask, well, what
proportion of US adolescents
have ever met criteria for
any eating disorder subtype?
And then this, again,
is just one example.
There's lots of other
questions that we
could have asked as well.
But with this question
in mind, then we
can think about collecting
data and analyzing
that data judiciously
to obtain our best
answer to that question.
So I worked with the National
Co-morbidity Survey Adolescent
Supplement, which was a survey
of about 10,000 US adolescents.
And in doing interviews on
different eating disorders,
we were able to obtain an
estimate of about 5% meeting
criteria for the
subtypes we measured.
Now I say on the slide
there that that's
sort of a lower bound
estimate, and that's
because we were very
mindful that we couldn't
measure all types of subtypes.
So when we discuss
the results, we've
made clear that we were only
getting certain subtypes.
We were being very clear about
the quality of our measurements
and issues with
the measurements.
But the point is that
we were putting it out
there as a dialogue
to keep on refining.
And indeed, since then
there's been a lot of work
that I've been a
part of where we
are able to measure
some of the subtypes
that we didn't get and try
to get better triangulation
of these estimates.
So now I want to turn to a
different kind of big question,
a causal question in a
sense, which is asking rather
than just trying to count who
has an eating disorder, who
meets criteria for these
different outcomes,
we want to do
something about it.
How could we prevent
an eating disorder?
How could we treat eating
disorders in our populations?
How could we reduce the
negative consequences of them?
And I'm not going
to boil this down
to one specific
sub-question, but I
want to give just kind of
a feel of the philosophy
of this causal inference
approach in these settings.
So again, we're
going to try first
to distill this down to a more
precise, relevant question.
And as we heard in the
previous session, ideally
we would have our
causal questions
like this answered with
well-conducted, large,
randomized trials.
So if we were
interested in looking
at an anti-bullying
campaign in schools,
we would randomize
some schools to receive
that campaign, some schools to
not, and follow that over time
and see if mental health
improves in those schools.
If we're interested in some
treatment for depression
like a new therapy,
we'd want to randomize
some patients to get it,
some patients to get standard
of care--
follow them over time
and see what is going on.
There's a lot of times, though,
where our questions are not
going to be feasibly
or ethically answered
with randomized trials.
And, in fact, for a lot
of pressing questions,
we also just don't want
to necessarily wait
for those trials to happen.
It might take decades
before we really
learned the long term
consequences of what
happens to a fetus prenatally,
just as one example.
And so because of
this, we have to rely
on observational studies.
And this comes back again
to some of the talks
that we heard earlier where
we have to somehow rely
on having our causal inferences
based on observational data.
What this means is that
we need to have a way
to link or observe data
to causal questions.
We need some sort of formal
mathematical language
for saying why our observed data
is linked to these questions
that we're trying to ask.
Now I don't want to
go into the specifics
of these different
mathematical languages.
There's a lot going on there.
In fact, maybe that could be an
entire next in science series
is just all the languages
of causal inference.
But one of the
commonalities that comes up
from really thinking
about these approaches
is that in order to
estimate a causal effect,
you have to have a precise
idea of the definition
that you're trying to obtain.
You have to know what
that starting question was
as precisely as you can.
Another way to think
of this is that you
have to have a really good
idea of what the protocol is
of that hypothetical trial you
wish you could have conducted
and you're using the
observed data for instead.
What we see is that if we
have ill-defined questions,
we end up with
ill-defined answers.
And so to the extent
that we really
do want to prevent eating
disorders from onsetting
or treat them better or improve
the lives of the patients who
have it, it's really
fundamental that we
start by making these
questions clear.
So when we're thinking
about this step-by-step
and we're trying to
take this big question
and distill it down, I
think it's really important
that we're mindful of
how we're distilling
this down to manageable
but very precise questions.
So what is that target trial
that we're trying to do?
What is the protocol exactly?
And then once
we've done that, we
can think through how we're
going to collect and analyze
data to answer that question.
And that might mean
doing something
like propensity score matching
or regression discontinuity
as we heard earlier.
That could be many other
kinds of statistical methods.
But I think the other thing
we need to be mindful of
is that these questions
or these analyses
are always tied back
to that question--
that there should be a
link between the analysis
we did and the question
that we're trying to ask.
And otherwise, we're
losing this opportunity
where we have
counterproductive answers
to questions that
we haven't actually
asked with our studies.
So with that in mind, I
wanted to just reflect
a little bit on the future of
epidemiology, or at least some
of the themes that I
really see set out there
by a lot of my colleagues,
including bigger data, better
data, and then novel uses of
some of the newer kinds of data
that we have access to.
So first in terms of big data.
We heard a little bit
about the promises
of electronic medical records.
We've thought through
things like registries.
There's a lot of
web-based data out there.
You can use Google searches
to predict flu epidemics.
You can use Facebook networks
to understand social contagion.
There's a lot of app-based data.
So if you're wearing a Fitbit,
we can, in research settings,
use that information to really
get an idea of your behaviors.
And then some of the
newer kinds of data
are big just by definition.
Genetics and
epigenetics and imaging
collects huge amounts
of data points.
So this is all really
exciting, and I
feel thrilled to be an
epidemiologist at an era
when these resources exist.
But I think we have to be
mindful that the big data alone
is not why it's exciting.
It's exciting
because we can tie it
to the questions
we're trying to ask,
and we can find a way to
answer those questions using
this data.
The same kind of thing could
be said for better data
that I think we're
getting better and better
about having more
valid measurements,
having repeated
measurements in individuals,
and then certainly getting
kinds of measurements that
let us peer into
human biology in a way
that we just weren't
able to decades before.
As just one example
of this, I work
with a couple of cohort
studies in the Netherlands
where we have
repeated brain imaging
on individuals in our studies.
So across childhood development
all the way through the elderly
we're able to kind of
see how the brains change
in these large studies.
And this is really
exciting and it really
opens these opportunities to
understand what healthy aging
looks like, how we can
prevent cognitive decline,
how we could promote
better brain development
during childhood, and so on.
But it's exciting
because we can tie
that data to these questions.
And then finally,
some of the newer data
allows us to have new
uses for this data.
And one example that's similar
to the quasi-experimental
designs we heard
about earlier is
this idea that
our genes could be
leveraged as a
natural experiment.
That, for example, if you
started with a question about
whether obesity affects
mental health outcomes,
you could look at
obesity-related genes
as a proxy for leveraging
this natural experiment
to try to answer that question.
And, again, that's
really exciting,
but these advanced
methods as well as
the bigger data
and the better data
alone are not going
to save us from having
imprecise questions.
That we need to
think through how
we're using this to get
back to those big questions,
back to the more precise
versions of them,
and really tie it all together.
And so what is the
future of epidemiology?
Well, when I think
about these big themes,
I think about them all as
fitting into this whole process
that I was going through.
That we're starting
with this big question.
We're distilling it down
to these more manageable
questions, collecting
and analyzing data,
and discussing the
results transparently.
And so these are offering
us huge opportunities
to kind of get at
this middle step,
but we need to be
mindful of where
it fits in the whole process.
So finally, I just wanted
to talk a little bit
about one of the key roles
of epidemiologists here,
which is being communicators
about all of this.
So part of the themes of what I
just went through highlight how
we communicate our results
to fellow epidemiologists
and fellow scientists,
but we also
have to be mindful
that this conversation
is much bigger than just
the scientific community.
We want our research to
be informing policies
at some level.
We want health care providers,
patients in communities,
to understand the
impact of these findings
and use that to inform
their decisions.
And ultimately, I see
that this communication
is improved by specifically
tie into questions
that we want to answer to the
way that we answer to them.
So the way we
collect and use data
to answer them as directly
and best as we can
and keep that process going.
And so with that, I
just want to thank
the numerous collaborators that
have shaped many of the ideas
that I went through
here, and thank you
all for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
- So I would like to thank all
of my co-presenters for just
beautifully setting up my talk.
No, I really want to
give you guys a big hug.
Let me know--
OK.
There we go.
So most of my work is--
I'm really interested in how
we as epidemiologists can
use data to make
progress in actually
reducing health disparities.
So I just started at
Johns Hopkins, and lo
and behold I found out
that a lot of my colleagues
are actually developing
and evaluating
interventions to reduce
disparities in health.
So, for example, reducing
differences in hypertension
control between
blacks and whites.
And a lot of these
interventions are
based on our current
understanding
of the epidemiology
and about logic models,
and so I'm wondering about
the sorts of questions
that we're asking
when we're informing
those sorts of interventions,
and what those interventions
should target.
So that's really what I'm going
to talk to you about today.
In my mind, I think
of it as a work
that's helping to
extend and further build
an epidemiology of
health disparities.
So before I begin,
I think there's
some background material
that needs to be covered.
And what do I mean by
a health disparity?
It's not just a difference
in diseases across groups.
The one definition that
really resonates with me
is one that was put forth
by Margaret Whitehead
for the World
Health Organization,
later updated by
Paula Braveman that
says that it's a disparity
in outcomes across socially
defined groups that results
through some mechanism
of injustice or a process
of marginalization.
So, for example, in the United
States racial ethnic minorities
because of the history
of Jim Crow, slavery,
structural racism,
segregation, housing
policy, interpersonal
discrimination, and also
lately implicit bias,
this has erected
significant political and
economic barriers which have,
number one, predisposed
racial ethnic minorities
to a higher likelihood
of being exposed
to environmental
toxins, psychological
stresses, impeded their
ability to lead and engage
in healthier lifestyles,
and also erected barriers
to quality care.
Just to make things a
little bit more concrete
about incorporating
this notion of justice
into our measurement
of other disparities,
it's actually useful
to look at the way
the Institute of Medicine
defines a disparity
in the receipt of health care.
They would define a disparity
in receipt of health care
that should capture differences
that arise in access to care,
or differences that arise
in the ability to pay,
because perhaps the clinician
in the face of
clinical uncertainty
is relying on poor
provider-patient communication,
or perhaps
stereotypes associated
with the social group
that a patient belongs to.
But if there were
actual differences
in the clinical need
between the populations
and there were differences
because of that,
that's not something that would
contribute to a disparity.
So, for example, in the
same psychiatric studies
that Sonya was
talking about, you
see a 60% lower prevalence of
major depression for blacks.
And so if you see
disparities in treatment
that may not necessarily
constitute a disparity.
You would want to estimate
disparities in anti-depressant
use among those who
have a clinical need
for antidepressants.
So it's clear that our
measures of disparity
should be capturing processes
that involve marginalization
and also injustice.
So in thinking of the health--
of the epidemiology
of health disparities,
I think it's also good
to go back to the basics.
Even though this has
been a central theme
throughout the day,
we're essentially
charged with understanding
how diseases are
distributed in the population.
And one of the major
hallmarks of epidemiology
has been to identify what
are the causal factors that
are actually influencing
disease with the ultimate goal
that we develop interventions
to improve population health.
This is a conceptual model by
the late Brian MacMahon, who
first chaired the
Department of Epidemiology
at the Harvard T.H Chan
School of Public Health.
And what-- and in
this model it reflects
the current thinking at the
time where chronic diseases--
it was realized that chronic
diseases weren't just caused
by a single agent but actually
a constellation of factors.
And a key insight of
his was that it's not
necessary to map out the entire
causal structure of a disease
or how all of these factors
coordinate and orchestrate
to cause disease.
But rather, it's important
to identify the particularly
salient causes that
intervening on them,
we could reduce a substantial
amount of disease and morbidity
in the population.
Now this aspect
of multi-causation
has been discussed
quite a bit today.
It's been a thorn in the
side of many epidemiologists,
because these causes are
correlated with each other.
And so in the absence
of a randomized trial--
say, if I was going to look
at the effect of eating
a healthier diet and whether I
could control my hypertension--
well, it might be that
patients like me also
live in neighborhoods
that are food deserts
and don't have opportunities
to buy healthier foods,
but the streets also may
not be safe to exercise on.
There may not be facilities
where I can go and exercise.
So you have this
correlation between being
able to eat a nutritious meal
and also exercise regularly.
And so without going into it,
we've heard about this today,
but I spent the last five
to eight years of my life
learning how to tease out this
association between causes
to try to map towards
a randomized trial.
Some of that involves tools
like propensity score matching,
regression discontinuity,
statistical adjustment.
This is a figure showing the
life expectancy in the United
States from 1975 to 2003 for
blacks and whites segregated
by sex.
What you see here is you
see that for all groups
you see an improvement in life
expectancy by at least six
to eight years, but you also
see that the racial difference
in life expectancy
over that period
has persisted for both
males and females.
And so the implication
of this figure to me
is that simply understanding
and intervening
on the determinants of health
or determinants of disease
may improve population health,
but it may not necessarily
translate into the
reduction of disparities.
One of the major thinkers
of health disparities
and their genesis
is Sherman James.
He was the pioneer of
studying health disparities.
And what-- in this model
what I particularly like
is that he's linking a
determinant of disease
to disparities and
outcomes, and he's
shown this in a very
comprehensive way.
So you see determinants
[INAUDIBLE] disease organized
as environmental factors also as
behavioral factors, the issues
of quality in health care.
Now in the text, you can't
really see this in the figure,
but in the text what
he goes on to say
is that actually the disparities
and these determinants
of the outcome that are driving
disparities in these outcomes.
So, for example,
disparities in incidence,
he's arguing, as you can see
by the weight of this arrow,
are driven largely
by disparities
in the environment and
air and housing quality
and in social relationships,
experiencing discrimination,
living in areas where there's
high concentrations of poverty.
Disparities in
prognosis, though,
are driven more by
disparities in the access
to and the utilization
of health care
whereas disparities in mortality
are driven more by prognosis
and also disparities in
care, with the acknowledgment
that all of these disparities
and these causal factors
are shaped by a larger political
and economic structures.
Now in thinking of
designing an intervention,
if we had a particular
outcome in mind,
well, we could target so many
different disparities here.
So how do we actually choose?
How do we do that?
And there are numerous
things that we
have to consider and trade off.
For example, how
much will it cost?
Is it feasible?
Do we have a window
of opportunity?
Do we have the political will?
Do we think that these
interventions are sustainable?
But I think the key
ingredient to all of this
is solid evidence
that intervening
to remove disparities
in a particular target
that we're pretty confident
that it will result in reducing
disparities in the outcomes.
So I would call
that effectiveness.
So how do we actually
use data to understand
how removing
disparities in a target
will actually lead to a
reduction in disparities
of outcomes?
Without going into the
specifics of this today,
I would say that most
of what we do today
is to quantify how disparities
in a particular target
statistically explain
disparities and outcomes.
The problem is is that
most of these approaches
are not explicitly accounting
for potential confounding
factors of those targets.
And so we're not ruling
out alternate explanations
of why those disparities
in those targets
may statistically explain
disparities and outcomes.
So if you think back to
that graph I showed you
about diet and nutrition, there
are these other compounding
factors.
And that's really what I'm
going to talk to you about today
is how we can improve these
methods to incorporate
explicit assumptions
about confounding control.
I'm going to do that by
walking through a very--
what I hope is an easy to
digest example analysis.
I'm going to re-use data from
a seminal paper by Roland Fryer
who's actually a renowned
economist here at Harvard
University, who showed that
if you look at the association
between race--
and some key outcomes,
including race, incarceration,
and unemployment--
if you adjust for
educational attainment,
you see that those disparities
reduce substantially.
And in the case of health, you
see that the disparity actually
vanishes.
And so essentially
what the data shows
is that disparities in
educational attainment or test
scores statistically explain
disparities in wages,
disparities in incarceration,
and disparities in health.
But there are alternate
explanations we could consider.
For example, it may
be that disparities
in educational
attainment are merely
a reflection of
disparities in childhood
socioeconomic conditions.
And so it begs the question,
will we see those same results
if we repeat the analyses to
actually control for childhood
socioeconomic conditions?
Another question is, well,
maybe the attractive target
could be test scores,
but maybe the target
could be to actually remove
disparities in childhood
socioeconomic conditions.
It's another question
we could ask.
A third question
is, well, what if we
could remove disparities
in both childhood
socioeconomic conditions
and test scores?
And so what I would
like to do is just
to walk through a couple of
example questions in this data,
incorporating, again, clear
assumptions about confounding.
And even though the
methods are going
to be really pretty
accessible and pretty simple,
they do draw on a power
counterfactual framework that
does map to a
hypothetical trial, which
allows you to really say if you
believe that you've measured
and adjusted for all the
appropriate confounders
that you can interpret it
as an intervention effect.
And so really what you're
asking is if we could intervene
to equalize these risk factors,
if we could intervene to remove
disparities in this target, how
would that impact disparities
in the outcome?
And so I'm going to run
through four analyses.
One, I'm going to
ask, what's going
to happen to the disparities
in wages, incarceration,
and in health if we could
remove disparities in childhood
socioeconomic conditions?
Then I'm going to ask, what
would happen to disparities
in our outcomes if among
those with the same childhood
socioeconomic status, we
could remove disparities
in educational attainment
as reflected in test scores?
And, again, I'm changing
the population here,
because I want to rule out
differences in childhood
socioeconomic status.
I'm going to account
for confounding.
The third one is, what if
we could intervene jointly
to remove disparities in
childhood socioeconomic status
and test scores?
And the last one is really, what
if we could remove disparities
overall irrespective of
childhood socioeconomic status,
which may be something that
we're more interested in.
So consider our
first intervention
to remove disparities in
childhood socioeconomic status.
Under some pretty
strong assumptions
and in this
simplified example, we
could estimate this
by fitting a model
for our outcome given race and
the covariate's age, gender,
and ethnicity.
And the race coefficient
in that model
would simply describe
the disparity
in the population
as we we've observed
for people the same age,
gender, and ethnicity.
Now if we refit that model and
we include a term for childhood
socioeconomic conditions, again,
under some strong assumptions
we would interpret that
as the remaining disparity
in our outcomes
after an intervention
to remove disparities in
childhood socioeconomic status.
The key assumption
here is that we've
adjusted for all the
confounders of childhood
socioeconomic status, and we've
heard a lot about that those
are usually pre-treatment
variables that
are also determinants
of whatever outcomes
that you're studying.
So conceptually, what
does this really mean?
So to help us sort through
this, I created some figures.
So on this top line here,
you see the distributions
of childhood
socioeconomic conditions,
educational attainment as
measured by test scores,
and the distributions
of our outcome.
And on the bottom, we have the
counterfactual distributions.
And this is for blacks
and then for whites.
So we have the
counterfactual distributions.
And so what the yellow
arrow represents
is the effect of
our intervention
to actively remove
disparities in childhood
socioeconomic conditions.
Namely, to shift the
distribution of childhood
socioeconomic conditions
such that they
align with the
distribution of childhood
socioeconomic
conditions for whites.
The faint dotted arrow
represents the propagation
of this effect to reduce
disparities in test scores
and also reduce disparities
in our outcomes finally.
So that was our
first intervention
to remove disparities
in childhood
socioeconomic conditions.
Our second intervention
is to remove disparities
in our outcomes among
those of the same childhood
socioeconomic conditions
and by removing disparities
in educational attainment
as reflected in test scores.
So, again, under some
pretty strong assumptions,
we could estimate this by
fitting a model for our outcome
given race on the covariate's
age, gender, and ethnicity,
but we also want to include in
this initial model childhood
socioeconomic conditions,
because we want
to account for confounding.
So, again, now the race
coefficient in that model
is going to give us our
observed disparity among people
who share the same socioeconomic
status in childhood.
Now we're going to add to that
model a term for test scores.
And what this and
the race coefficient
in this new model would equal--
again, under some
strong assumptions--
what the disparity we would
observe after an intervention
to remove disparities
in test scores
among those who have the same
childhood socioeconomic status.
Again, this is
under an assumption
that we've measured all the
confounders of test scores
and adjusted for them.
So heuristically what's
going on here is we're--
I'm showing you the
distributions of childhood
socioeconomic
conditions, and then I'm
showing you the black and white
distributions for test scores
among those with low
socioeconomic status
and among those with high
socioeconomic status,
and then also for the outcomes.
Again, conditional on
childhood socioeconomic status.
And on the bottom line, we have
our counterfactual disparities.
So the intervention doesn't
touch socioeconomic status
at all, but rather
it's within levels
or among those who
share the same childhood
socioeconomic status.
So there are some details
I put into this figure
that I want to point out.
The first detail is that for
those with lower childhood
socioeconomic status,
it's highly plausible
that the distribution of
test scores for both blacks
and whites is actually lower
than the population average.
And then, again, for those with
high childhood socioeconomic
conditions, their distributions
are going to be higher.
The implication of this is that
when we do our intervention
to shift the black distribution
to where the white distribution
is, for those with low
socioeconomic status
we're not going to
move it that far.
But this is problematic,
because this is where
blacks are overrepresented.
And so our intervention
to reduce disparities
in educational attainment among
those with the same childhood
socioeconomic status
is probably not
going to achieve as much
as we would like it to.
But yet this is
the very analysis,
this is the principal
analysis that we have to do,
because we want to
count for confounding.
My childhood
socioeconomic status.
So our third
intervention is to look
at what could happen if we could
intervene to reduce disparities
in both childhood socioeconomic
conditions and also
educational attainment as
reflected in test scores.
So as similar to
before, we're going
to start with a model
for outcome given race
and the covariate's initial.
Race coefficient
is the disparity
we observe in the population.
If we add in terms for childhood
socioeconomic status and also
test scores, the
new race coefficient
is going to-- we could interpret
that as the residual disparity
we would see under an
intervention to jointly remove
disparities in childhood
socioeconomic status
and also test scores.
Here, we have a stronger
confounding assumptions
that we need to meet.
We need to ensure that there
is no unmeasured confounding
for childhood socioeconomic
status, and also
no unmeasured confounding
for test scores.
So this is a stronger
assumption that we need than we
used for our other analyses.
And so heuristically, these
are observed distributions
for childhood socioeconomic
status test scores and outcome,
and you can see
our intervention is
to shift the distributions of
childhood socioeconomic status
and test scores for blacks to
their respective distributions
among whites and observe some
reduction in the disparity
in the outcomes.
So I've described to you
so far three interventions.
The first intervention would
be to reduce disparities
in childhood
socioeconomic status.
The second one is
where we wanted
to look at the impact
of removing disparities
in test scores,
but we had to do it
among a special group of people
who share the same childhood
socioeconomic status
because we wanted
to control for confounding.
And this third one
was we said, well,
let's just try to
intervene on both.
But really an intervention
that we might think about
is, well, what if we could just
move disparities in test scores
without even
looking at childhood
socioeconomic conditions but
account for the confounding
there?
That's the real trick.
That's the real tough one there.
And we're interested
in doing this,
because it may be more
feasible to remove disparities
in educational attainment
than to remove disparities
in economic conditions.
So without getting into
too much of the math,
it turns out to
estimate this, to answer
this sort of question, we can't
rely on the typical subtraction
of race coefficients.
And the reason why is that
an intervention to remove
disparities in
test scores overall
is going to partially block
the effects of disparities
in childhood
socioeconomic conditions.
And so without-- so if we
think of it another way,
the effect of childhood
socioeconomic status
on our outcomes is partially
mediated by test scores.
So if we intervene,
we're going to block
part of the effect of
disparities in childhood
socioeconomic conditions.
And in English the way
that this is estimated
in these linear models
is simply to first start
with the disparity reduction
upon equalizing test scores
among those with the same
childhood socioeconomic status.
That was our second
intervention.
Then we're going to add to that
how much the disparity would
be reduced under removing
disparities in childhood
socioeconomic status.
That was our first intervention.
But we're not going to
add all of that back in.
We're only going to
add in the amount
by which the effect of childhood
socioeconomic status is not--
well, is mediated
by test scores.
And so heuristically
all we're doing here
is intervening to shift the
entire distribution of test
scores among blacks
to where whites is,
but we're not doing anything to
the distribution of childhood
socioeconomic conditions.
So in our re-analysis of
the data, what do we see?
Well, we see as we would
expect that the most effective
intervention is to remove
disparities in both childhood
socioeconomic conditions
and also test scores.
So it would removed 74% of
the disparities in wages,
81% of disparities
in incarceration,
and completely eliminates all
the disparities in health.
What's fascinating,
though, is that if we just
were to remove disparities in
educational attainment alone
as measured in test scores,
it's not that far behind.
We could remove two
thirds of the disparities
in wages, two thirds of the
disparities in incarceration,
and once you account
for the standard errors,
all of the disparity in health.
What's also interesting
is that it's
as effective or more
effective than intervening
to reduce disparities
in childhood
socioeconomic conditions.
And so just looking at
wage-- disparities in wages
here, if we removed
disparities in childhood
socioeconomic conditions
we remove about a quarter
of the disparity.
But if we were to intervene
to remove disparities
in educational attainment
as reflected in test scores,
we would remove two
thirds of the disparity.
And finally, our--
and eventually we're
going to remove disparities
among those who have
the same socioeconomic status.
Remove 65% of the
disparity among those
who have the same socioeconomic
status, but it bears pointing
out that this is a
less ambitious goal
because the initial
disparity is smaller.
And so if you just
look at that--
the difference between where
you start and where you end up,
you can see that it's a
less effective intervention.
Also, the nature of what we
mean by educational attainment
is important, which gets back
to Sonja's point about what
question are we asking.
If we were to try to equalize
total years of education,
we see that the
disparity is actually
as effective as equalizing
childhood socioeconomic status,
or in some cases less effective.
So there are some limitations.
We used really simple models and
worked with Tyler VanderWeele,
which this is based on.
We've extended these to
more general outcomes,
non-linear outcomes.
We have non-parametric
formulae that
can incorporate interactions,
account for confounders that
are descendants of race
or whatever social status
that you're using.
In future work, we hope
to extend these out
to longitudinal outcomes,
including repeated measures
and time to event outcomes.
And also in other work,
it's of great interest today
you hear a lot of people
talking about intersectionality.
So people are not just
marginalized in one way.
They may be marginalized because
of their socioeconomic position
and also their race.
In other work, I've
talked about the notion
of joint disparities and also
intersectional disparities,
and it is definitely possible
to map these sorts of analyses
to disparities
along multiple axes.
The implications of our study,
though-- what we found is we
actually confirmed
the results of Fryer,
but we've added
important information.
Number one, we've
ruled out disparities
in childhood
socioeconomic status
as an alternate explanation.
It really does look
like disparities
in educational attainment
as reflected in test scores
is really the
important target here.
So what are the implications
for the next steps
in health disparities research?
And I think Sonya
stole my thunder here,
but what I would like to say is
that we have a real opportunity
here to do these sorts of
analyses very carefully.
This was a toy example
here, but when we actually
have cohort data or
exquisite medical records,
we can actually look at
what is the thing that we're
trying to intervene to
reduce disparities in.
For example, if we're
looking at it adherence,
or if we're looking
at nutrition,
at whatever target
that we're interested
in, we should
think about what are the
confounders of that target.
And then we should
also try to ensure
that we have longitudinal data.
We should also try to
ensure that we respect
the temporality
of our confounders
in our targets and
our outcomes, just
like we do in careful and
rigorous epidemiologic studies.
We have a real
opportunity to do this.
Now all this talk
about confounding,
the big elephant in the room
is unmeasured confounding.
Which our first speaker
eloquently pointed out
that sometimes you
have these variables
measured, but many times
they're not measured.
But what I would argue
is that epidemiology
of health disparities
is actually
in a better position than a
de novo study in epidemiology.
And the reason is is because
usually health disparities
analyses are built on existing
knowledge about epidemiology.
So, for example, if
we're just starting out
where we're trying to identify
how diseases distribute
in the population,
well, that's the step
where we're actually describing
disparities in disease.
When epidemiology is
doing the hard work
of trying to identify the
causal factors, teasing out
what are the other
risk factors, are we
doing the best adjustments
for confounding?
This is really where
the field of disparities
would still be
determining what are
the disparities in
those determinants that
are being identified by
those epidemiologic studies.
When we go onto
designing strategies
to improve population
health, part of that we're
thinking about, well, how
can we actually reduce
these disparities?
But we have all this
knowledge that we've
gleaned from these
epidemiologic studies.
So when I would go and
pull these medical records
and think about what are
the variables that I need
to adjust for, well,
for disease areas
like cardiovascular disease,
we know what the major risk
factors are.
We know what needs
to be adjusted for.
And even if our cohorts
don't have them,
it at least gives
us a clear list
of things that
need to be measured
in whatever cohorts or synthetic
cohorts that we're designing.
So I'd argue that, yes, the
confounding structures are
something to be concerned
about, but we're
in a much better
position when trying
to do these sorts of analyses
that I'm describing here.
And hopefully these
sorts of robust analyses
are what's going to be used
to build conceptual models
for designing interventions.
Another application of the
work that I'm presenting here
is that how we
define a disparity
matters exquisitely
for its explanation.
As I said before, a disparity
measure, particularly when
it comes to treatment
of care, would
condition on certain things
and not others, right?
So in the case of disparities
in anti-depressant treatment,
we would condition
on clinical need.
If we went on to condition
on access to care,
we're going to miss
some of the disparities
among people who aren't
able to access treatment.
And so what that
means is when we
have our covariates that
need to be adjusted for,
we have a choice.
So we can condition on
things like age and family
history and gender
and prognostics score,
and we can adjust for them
that way through conditioning.
But for all of the
other things that
are sort of tied to injustice,
like socioeconomic status,
health literacy and
insurance, where you live,
we don't have to
adjust on those things.
I mean, we don't have to
condition on those things.
We can adjust for them
without changing our disparity
measure, which is important.
So really, it's the hope
that with these sorts
of careful principled
analyses that we can develop
refined conceptual models that
will help us provide better
estimates of how
effective it might
be to intervene on
one particular target
versus another.
Thank you for listening, and
I welcome your questions.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you both.
Those were really
terrific talks.
I learned a bunch
of stuff from them.
So we'll open up for
questions, and maybe--
anybody's got a burning
one, you can start.
But if not, I will
ask a couple of mine.
So Sonya.
So partly because I'm
fascinated by these studies,
could you talk a little bit--
you flashed up the picture
of the cell phone study.
Can you tell folks a little
bit about those kind of studies
and what you're doing and--
- Sure.
- --how those work?
I think it's a really
interesting example
of better data.
- Sure.
- Yeah.
- And I'm happy to hear that
you have some experience with it
as well.
- Barely.
- Yeah.
So one of the main
starting points
in this cohort study I
mentioned based in Rotterdam
that I work with
is we're starting
to have these kind
of app-based studies
where we give participants
in our studies these
prompts on their cell phone
to answer certain questions
over time.
And so just thinking
about something
like eating disorders,
if you're trying
to understand what
causes someone
to engage in a compensatory
behavior today,
and you're trying to
understand that behavior today,
you want the context of
what happened on that day.
And so these app-based
kind of things
allow you to get real time
collection of that data
rather than asking a
survey every two or three
years or something like that.
And so I think that-- yeah.
There's a lot of opportunities
to refine your questions
to ideas of what's happening
at the hourly limit,
or the daily limit,
or things like that
with these kinds of studies.
- Yeah.
So some of the things you can--
we're doing a study that's
sort of similar to that,
also looking at some
eating behaviors.
You can look at perhaps what was
the potential emotional trigger
that day, or you
can use GPS data--
obviously with everybody's
permission to use it--
and see was-- were they
walking by a Dunkin' Donuts?
You can really get down to
a very fine-grained level.
I see Burt's got
a question, too.
Specific to this.
Yeah?
- Two great talks.
Thank you very much.
I have a question--
a question for Sonya.
You say I would
like to basically do
a trial to study efficacy,
but I can't very often.
So let's design a study
to mimic then the trial.
So that is what you want
to do to do a good study.
And you also say I would like
to refine the question in such
a way that I have a meaningful
answer to a good question.
Now very often-- in
the past-- what is it,
five to 10 years--
clinical trials
are being criticized for
being not relevant in terms
of the question they address.
This tension between what you
want from a design viewpoint
and from a relevance viewpoint.
Can you discuss that a bit?
- Sure.
So I'll just take
one of the criticisms
I know for trials,
which is that they often
are focused on really
select patient populations.
So just to stick with the
eating disorder example--
if you want them to meet exactly
the criteria for anorexia
nervosa, and you want to rule
out co-morbidities and things
like that, you might
really restrict the ages.
You might really restrict
it to females and so on.
And so you might get
a really good estimate
in that population
in that trial,
but it doesn't generalize
to larger populations.
What I would argue is actually
in observational studies,
you have this opportunity to
make it exactly the population
you care about.
So like when we have
electronic medical records
or we have big data
opportunities, if we think
about the population we want
to ask the question for,
we can make it more relevant
and tie it to that population.
So I see it sort of
as maybe not the trial
that we would have
conducted, but the trial
we really wish we
could have conducted
is what you're
trying to emulate.
Yeah.
- I've got a question for John.
This is in the fantasy
baseball camp kind of realm.
You talked about those
unmeasured confounders,
and I think very
often when we're
talking about social
disparities there's
a lot of elephants
in the room and a lot
of unmeasured confounders.
And I think my question
for you would be, you had--
for that analysis you had the
National Longitudinal Survey
of Youth, which is actually
a pretty detailed data set.
What would you ideally want
to answer the question-- first
of all, what are the
particular questions that
are most pressing to you?
And then to get at those, what
are some of the pieces of data
you'd really love to have?
- Well, I think--
so one area that I'm
actually starting to work in
is in hypertension control.
So I'm really interested
in lifestyle behaviors
versus disparities in adherence.
I think what I tried to stress
in the talk was that it's not
really that you need the
confounders to be balanced
across racial groups.
You need them to be balanced
across exposure groups
within racial groups
So it's actually
the same assumption
that we use in our standard
epidemiologic cohort analyses.
It's no different.
It's the same thing.
So in terms of those,
I really just want
to make sure that the
major risk factors
for cardiovascular disease
are actually measured well
among both groups.
I think the challenges is
finding cohorts or follow-up
studies where you have adequate
data on all social groups
that you're interested in.
I think that's the challenge.
- Yep.
Yep.
- Hi.
I have a question for
Dr. Jackson as well.
So again, like with unmeasured
confounding and everything
like that, and I was--
kept thinking about
the first example
you gave about depression
and clinical need.
I guess like every
disparity that you
see doesn't necessarily
mean necessarily
like a difference
in people getting
what they need
essentially when it comes
between blacks and whites.
But I think--
I guess I would push on
that, because when it comes--
I mean, isn't that
still a symptom
of disparities in,
say, health care?
So just because there's
a higher prevalence
in, say, depression among--
or at least clinical depression
among whites, I mean,
does that still mean that
there can still potentially
be the same level prevalence
of depression in blacks
or even more so, but
it's because of stigma
in mental health in the
community and things like that,
and also barriers
to health care.
That's like another unmeasured
thing we're not looking at.
So even if you do a condition
on it in your analysis,
it doesn't necessarily
account for it.
- Well, there's a lot there.
I think-- so there are--
so in the Psych EPU literature,
you see a couple of things.
Like, you see a lower prevalence
of both current and lifetime
depression among blacks, but
you see a worse prognosis.
So you see more--
you see a higher prevalence
of recurrent depression
and also chronic
forms of depression,
and you see poorer function.
So I'm not--
I think if you are
thinking about clinical--
once you condition
on clinical need,
I'm not sure that you're
missing disparities in treatment
if you're talking about people
who are showing up initially
on a first episode, or if
it's a recurrent episode.
I'm not sure if I'm answering
your question adequately,
but I'm not sure how
you would be missing
the disparity by really--
so if you think about
a disparate treatment,
you're saying that people
who need the medication
are getting it less
often than someone who's
in all other instances
clinically like them
but of a different race.
And the key issues
with that is that they
both need the medication.
Whether or not--
there's a lot of debate
about our estimates in the
psychiatric epidemiology
studies.
Is it because of selection bias?
There's a large chunks of the
African-American population
missing from household surveys.
Is it because of
differences in how
people are answering
the tools that we use
to measure depression?
Is it because of differences in
reporting to somatic symptoms
versus more
psychological symptoms?
But none of those
alternate explanations
have been compelling, at
least up to this point.
So most people believe
estimates that the prevalence
of major depression is, in fact,
lower among African-Americans
So really the
disparities in treatment
should really be conditional
on clinical need.
- Sonya, something that you
put up during your talk really
resonated with me, and that's
the notion of epidemiologists
communicating with
non-epidemiologists,
which is the focus
of this session here.
And I'd love for both
of you to reflect
on that, because I felt
like in my training,
I wasn't trained
on how to do that.
I can write a scientific
article like nobody's business,
but I can't communicate
with the public.
And yet so many of our public
health messages are known.
Like, people know wear a condom.
People know get vaccinated.
And our approach-- my
impression of our approach
has just been to lambaste the
public with more and more data.
But so-- is it a
function of our training?
Like, how do you think
we can go about doing
a better job of this?
- You know, this is a tough one.
I think-- I don't know.
Part of it's a challenge
of just the history
of how we've
conducted the science,
and that I think earlier
on we were really getting
at just pure associations.
And so we've really
trained the public
to view a risk factor as
sort of being associated
with a disease, but maybe
not necessarily thinking
through in terms of gradations
about the particular type
of question that we're asking.
So, for instance,
duration of exposure
to a particular risk factor
or among a certain subgroup.
I'm not sure I actually
have an answer for that.
I mean, part of it has to do
with the state of our science
when it goes out to
the public, and how
much control we have over
that to actually build
in qualifiers.
I'm not sure I have--
to be honest, I just
don't have a good--
it's a problem, I
think, in that we
have a lot of
over-interpretation
of our scientific results.
I think most people,
when you explain
the limitations of
epidemiology in terms
of trying to make
fair comparisons,
most people really
do understand that.
But in terms of communicating
really finely detailed
granular answers to
questions, I'm not sure
that we're really there yet.
- Yeah.
I'd probably echo
some of that that--
I think of--
certainly like when I
talk to my parents or
non-epidemiologists
in my friendship
or family circles.
Everyone is very trained to
know that correlation is not
causation, right?
And that that's like--
we get that from a high
school statistics course
or middle school science class.
And I think that's built
as this level of skepticism
where you can just kind
of pick the studies you
want to believe if they support
your beliefs about the world.
And I think maybe something the
epidemiologist could do better
is try to train people
to think through how
if our question
really is causal.
If I'm trying to decide,
should I take that treatment
or should I recommend
this change in the schools
or change in my
hospital policies
or whatever it might be, how
can I support that empirically,
and how can I
understand really what
the assumptions are underlying
that empirical estimate?
I'm not sure if that can
happen in high schools.
I don't know if that's just--
when we convey our studies
to really be transparent about
all the assumptions upon which
they rest, because
maybe that just
makes more skeptics
about it because they
are strong assumptions.
But I think that's probably
where I would start
is just trying to revisit that
when our question is causal,
we should be explicit
that that's the question
and then how confident
we are in those answers.
- If I could add one more thing.
I think what would be--
in addition to what
Sonya talked about--
would be really
helpful is perhaps
as epidemiologists
instead of saying
what the question
has answered, maybe
list out what it
hasn't answered.
- Yeah.
- So for a lot of
medications, we
don't have data
on long term use.
So for psychotropics, what's
the actual effectiveness
five years out, six
years out, 10 years out?
Do we actually have
good data on that?
I think a lot of times when
we're thinking about these risk
factors or things
that we encounter,
there are certain
assumptions that we
make about how we're
using them and what
the risks are without
any data to support that.
So I think pointing out
perhaps what the questions are
that aren't being answered.
If we list those all
along with the question
that we did answer,
it would probably
help frame what we know
and what we don't know.
- Maybe just one other
thing I would add just
thinking about this more
is among epidemiologists,
I think we're good at doing
sensitivity analyses to try
to understand how robust
our conclusions are,
but that could be communicated
better as well, right?
There's a lot of times
that we show something
and we say there's
an effect, and then
that makes some New
York Times headline
and it gets lost in the noise
of how confident we are in that.
But, I mean, we're confident
that vaccines save lives.
We're confident that
vaccines do not cause autism.
That smoking causes lung cancer.
That safe storage practices
of guns saves lives.
Like, we know those things,
and we know those things
because we've done a lot
of sensitivity analyses.
And I wonder if there's a way
to communicate that better too.
Yeah.
- Thank you both.
I think just piggybacking
on the conversation
about communicating results,
and also specifically John,
you invoked this third part of
the definition of epidemiology.
It's not just describing the
distribution determinants.
It's using that knowledge to
apply to improve the health.
So a question
specifically for you,
John, and then for both of you--
what is our role in the context
of your findings with test
scores?
It's easy to now have
this take home message
after that complicated
mythologic kind
of decomposition of the
effect to point to that,
but obviously that's
also multi-factorial what
goes into test scores,
and that's still
kind of a proxy for
many other things
that also intersect with
many different planes
of our experience.
But just can you guys
both speak to kind
of what our role is
as epidemiologists
in that next step of
moving things forward,
or if you have
ideas of what that
could look like within your
specific research [INAUDIBLE].
- So in terms of--
like in terms of
being a methodologist,
I'm not an expert in
education by any means.
But in terms of,
like, where I see
the work that I'm
doing methodologically
is really a first step.
I haven't said
anything about how
you're going to go about
reducing disparities,
but if you know exactly what the
boundaries like what you could
achieve then you
can actually start
to think about how can I
design observational studies
to actually get at more
detailed interventions
that I could perhaps map out.
So if you designed a
target trial to say,
if we intervened on
these two social groups
in particular ways, what would
the reduction and the disparity
be, and have very explicit
intervention strategies.
And that-- so sort of I
see as a winnowing down.
So we have all these
targets, and then
given sort of an
upper bound of what
we could achieve by
removing disparities then
we can actually get to finer
intervention strategies.
Along the way, I think it's
important to also leverage
actual policy changes
and actual interventions
in natural experiments
to actually see
what real interventions
have accomplished.
And so I sort of take
these sorts of analyses
as guiding our focus about what
to do follow-up studies on.
And at the end of
the day, it's going
to take real experiments
to actually get
robust evidence for this.
- Yeah.
I'm not sure I can add anything
better to what you just said,
so I won't even try.
- Hi.
I have multiple questions,
but I'll limit it to one.
Well, actually maybe two.
First, I was very interested
in the disparity in general
for black males versus
white males [INAUDIBLE]
going on and seeing not that
black males life expectancy
is going up, but the
white males is going down.
The big issue that's
being made about that.
One of the things
that I'm really
interested in when you
mentioned about test
scores and education--
recently, Mrs. Obama
was shocked that they
want to roll back the standards
for the food, the quality
of food that
students have, which
is [INAUDIBLE] to brain which
contributes to test scores.
And I don't know if there's an
opportunity for you to-- not
you personally, but
you in the general--
to speak about the correlation
between being fed well
and being able to perform
to get to a higher
socioeconomic status.
- I think there's been
a lot of research that
shows that providing
lunch and food programs
actually improve
outcomes in education.
But one thing that I think
there is an opportunity
to sort of use is
to look at the data
of the effect of
this policy change
on outcomes for both whites and
blacks across different sectors
of the nation.
That's a first step of
something that we could do.
- Was there a second question?
Oh, we've got another--
- Thank you very much.
I was very struck-- especially
Sonya-- but on all four
of your presentations today
about how accessible it
was to non-epidemiologists.
And I guess I wanted to go
back to the communications
theme that has been talked about
a little bit in so much as,
do you see that there are
natural partners or people
in the public that you should--
that you should
look at as advocates
or develop different
types of partnerships
so that the messages
that you're bringing out
can be more
effectively delivered?
- That's a great question.
So without having thought
about it before you asked
that question at least,
off the top of my head
I would say certainly there's
a lot of opportunities
to work with more
nonprofit organizations,
or maybe like the
heads of hospitals,
if you're a researcher targeting
how we deliver treatment
or something like that.
I'd say the other
big partnership
that I see is just the media.
The media is not necessarily
that great at reporting
on scientific findings, because
there is this balance of you
don't want sensationalism.
You don't actually want media
to be all about one study.
As I tried to emphasize,
it's about this whole process
and about continuing a
conversation about where
we are with the science.
But maybe that'd
be a place to start
that if you get
newspaper articles or TV
coverage of these studies
to be better articulated
in the context of where
they're coming from.
That might propagate further
into the communities more.
I don't know if you
have other thoughts.
- I don't have too
many other thoughts.
I think it's important
to partner with the end
users of your research.
And so I think
getting them on board
early on helps you ask
better questions that
are more informed.
So I'm primarily
work and methods,
and so I have to partner
with clinicians and hospital
administrators to
see exactly what are
the types of interventions
that they're interested in,
and how can the analyses that
I'm doing actually [INAUDIBLE].
And if they're there
at the ground level,
then I have an opportunity
to also educate them
about what's possible with these
results and what they mean,
what they answer and also
what they don't answer.
I think sometimes
things can fall short
when you do your
analyses in a vacuum,
and then take them to
a stakeholder or a user
and try to explain all
the intricacies of what
you're doing.
It could be problematic.
- Maybe just to go with
that a little bit more--
I could see too using a paradigm
that I was walking through
with the step-by-step to
get the end users more
to help with the precise
questions at the beginning,
too, so that they're
actually engaging
in the whole process with you.
- This is a question for
all four of our presenters.
We've talked about the
conclusions that epidemiology
can reach, the importance
that these conclusions have
on policy, and the importance
of communicating properly
to be able to affect policy.
Communication,
however, also depends
on the receptivity
of your audience,
and we have a great
difference in the audiences
that you're addressing.
Our first presenter
is addressing
a audience which is very
receptive in general
to the ideas.
Our last presenter is addressing
the current political power
structure, which is not going
to be receptive necessarily
to these ideas.
How did the four of you in
both your collective realms
and your individual
specialized realms
deal with these difficulties
of communicating effectively
and productively?
- That's a great question.
- I'll start.
Well, no.
First, I would-- I really want
to thank you for that question.
It's a challenge, because you
have to master so many things.
Not just the methods,
the statistics, but also
the history, the
policies, and there
are a lot of things that are
areas where you can learn more.
I think for me--
that's a really tough question
of communicating effectively.
I think part of it is learning
that I can't really do this
alone and partnering
with other people who
are doing this work who are also
doing this on the ground level,
partnering with people who
are engaged in the community,
people who are actually
developing policy.
And maybe that's an
opportunity for me
to sort of understand
how to frame
my analyses in a way that's
both clear and also effective.
I think the subtext
to your question
is the weight on facts
today, especially facts
that you don't agree with, it's
a lot harder now to come with--
to come and present data,
especially when it challenges
someone's preconceived notions.
I'm not sure I have the best
answer for that at this moment.
I think what I've
decided to do is
to try to do the best
science that I can do,
and if someone's mind is not
amenable or open to data,
there's not really
much that I can do.
But I can be persuasive
to people around them,
or I can also be persuasive
to things on other dimensions,
such as costs or other things
that they might care about.
- Yeah.
I guess I might add
some of my heroes
in epidemiology work
in firearm safety
and looking at how we can save
lives by storing guns safer,
treating them safer,
things like that.
Obviously, a very
hot political topic.
I think, though,
some of the successes
that I see in how they engage
in the science there is first
just acknowledging
that they're doing
these scientific
estimates-- that they're not
giving a moral argument to it.
They're not part of the
larger questions of liberties
versus safety and all of that.
They're just trying to
give these estimates
of how many lives could be
saved or how many injuries
could be prevented
and trying to do that.
And then I think when they
communicate that they really
look for people in
the communities that
can start having
that conversation
and propagating the
conversation a little more.
So focusing on parents of
kids, because everybody
wants our kids to be safe, or
focusing on the instructors
of gun safety courses.
And I think that
that's maybe how
you do it is it's an incremental
conversation that you have.
But recognizing that you're
doing the best science
you can do, and that's part
of a larger story of how
we function as communities.
Yeah.
- [INAUDIBLE] with myself and
my colleagues [INAUDIBLE] So
in South Africa, we worked with
the South African government
quite a bit.
So what has required
us to actually build
that relationship well
is listening to them
and not going in
there as a foreigner
and forcing whatever
we've believed
to be either an association
or something that's
causal on them.
So it is really listening
and having a conversation.
And like you said, Sonya, is
doing it incrementally and not
overloading people
with information,
because it doesn't help.
But we have-- it Took.
A long time for us to
develop these relationships
with the South African
government and people
specifically in there
who will help to actually
have an effect on policy.
It's that conversation
that's been over the last
probably decade that has
helped us really kind of
communicate effectively and
change policy at that level.
Yeah.
- I just-- I have a
couple of thoughts.
I don't have anything additional
to what's already been shared.
I agree with that.
At the hospital
where I work, the IRB
has community members
that sit on it
as well as studies
that we enroll.
We usually try to have community
representation to ensure
that it's asking a question
that people actually care about
and that it's
represented accurately.
And some-- just an
anecdote from my own work.
Before I was doing
this, my dissertation
was on vaccination and
vaccine-preventable diseases.
And naive me thought that
everyone would just get
vaccinated once they
saw this science, right?
How can you argue against that?
I'm no longer naive to that.
And so one thing I think
we can do a better job--
and I started to do
this-- was let's reach out
to the anti-vaccination
community
rather than just scoff at them.
So I engaged one of
their representatives
and said, all right.
What do you propose?
What do you want to have happen?
If you are so adamant about
not getting vaccinated,
what's your proposal?
Because one thing we can all
agree on is that this is--
I mean, we don't want--
we don't want otherwise
preventable diseases
from making a resurgence
as they're doing now.
So what are your alternatives?
It was really an
enlightening conversation
that I had with this
person, and I actually
wanted to write this
up and publish it
in just like a magazine.
Unfortunately I didn't
get permission from them,
but it was still--
I think that's
something that we can do
is just reach out
and ensure that we
have a balanced
viewpoint on things, too.
That we're not just--
because in some ways,
it is kind of insular in the
community that I work in.
Like, everyone kind of thinks
alike in the public health
program, and we all believe
that these are the interventions
that people should have.
But it's really interesting
when you get outside of that
and talk to other people
that have just as strong--
and are very eloquent
speakers as well--
opinions to the contrary.
It's very-- it's helpful to kind
of humble your work in a way
as well.
So I think that's--
to me, at least, like having
community representation
and having a
dialogue with people
that are just outside
of your direct role.
- Well, thank you all very much.
We've got a reception
outside, so please first
join me in thanking
actually all four
of our speakers [INAUDIBLE].
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]